[Music]
hey I'm Sean o probably and welcome to
the detail scholarship I got discovered
on MySpace I guess when I got into it I
thought I was gonna be runways travel
all the time and you know different
countries every day beautiful gorgeous
girl models and it's kind of different
and what's the biggest difference
between what you thought it was going to
be one reality well you know when people
see this interview they're gonna think
we're doing in a fancy studio and
everything and they don't really realize
we're doing to the staircase and if you
could tell Sean O'Brien Kennesaw Georgia
advice you give them advice now before
you got into all of this what are you
telling no Jagermeister let's make a
Meister what do you think is your
signature Sean okay look and can you to
us looks like a bar what do you think is
your best body part or party your body
my ankles
and why can't you tell beautiful
voluptuous my drink of choice lately has
been a hot toddy Jack honey hot water a
little bit of lemon ginger here's a cold
learned that from a flight attendant
what's the best our worship for you
taken for work they are in the same job
I went to Bali for a daily three weeks
ago in father's beautiful I was in the
middle of jungle I could touch a monkey
he's on my shoulder but I went through
believe in a Bali took me twenty seven
hours to get there you lose it in so
then it's Wednesday then we work I wake
up I work and we fly out and then it
takes 27 hours back little go to touch
your monkey
[Music]